hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a science fiction and thriller
movie called minor premise
the movie begins with ethan kochar a
brilliant neuroscientist who's currently
mourning both personal and professional
losses because his father paul died some
time ago just before completing the
project and the credit for breakthroughs
they made together is going mostly to
the dead man
later on we see ethan is replaying his
memory with his ex-girlfriend named ali
in front of his students he then
explains that it is possible because of
his invention our 9x allows data
transfer from our brain to external
drives he states that before he took
over the r9x could only show very blurry
pictures because of that groundbreaking
work ethan wants to take his research
for the next device our 10 to the next
level which enables us to isolate
sections of the brain that impact
emotions or behavior ethan's belief is
that the same emotional markers that
fine-tune these blurry images might also
serve as a roadmap through a person's
consciousness
finding them means isolating them
isolating them means manipulating them
in the future he will be able to erase
trauma subdue triggers and reorganize
brains to become their perfect version
the next day ethan attends the awarding
ceremony of the outstanding r9x
discovery
there the co-creator of the r9x and also
ethan's dad's friend dr malcolm bloom
gives an opening speech saying that paul
was a very brilliant and smart person
malcolm then approaches ethan and tells
him that the next day ethan has to
present his attend progress to the
committee but ethan is not ready as he
has not found the right equation for the
device
at night ethan is approached by his
ex-girlfriend while drinking alone
we discovered that she was the early
programmer for the device
she knows ethan has to present tomorrow
and wants to help him to prepare but is
rejected
ethan gets back to his home in a very
messed up condition and finds one of his
dad's old notebooks on the table
while talking to his mom and reading the
book at the same time he suddenly
discovers an equation written on a
hidden page of the book realizing that
it must be the equation he has been
seeking for
running out of time for tomorrow's
presentation he rushes to his basement
lab and starts typing the equation into
the devices program
suddenly a calibrated map of his brain
containing ten sections appears on the
screen with each of them showing unique
characteristics
one of the sections section five which
he claims to be his core intellect
section is labeled he is going to
isolate section 5 and attenuate the
others for an hour hoping that the
intellect section will be dominant and
will make him smarter after completing
the code he decides to try the beta
version of the device on himself
three minutes later
he wakes up and feels no discernable
boost in cognitive awareness as nothing
happened
he suddenly falls asleep at the lab
the next day he finds himself waking up
in the living room it is already 10 a.m
and he realizes that he is late for the
presentation but when he walks out of
his house he suddenly feels dizzy in
blackout
suddenly he finds himself standing in
front of a strange painting on the
whiteboard when he looks at his phone it
is already 11 am discovering that he has
just experienced a full memory loss for
an hour
only awake for 5 minutes and 55 seconds
he starts to feel dizzy again in
blackout
the scene jumps to an hour later ethan
is talking with her mom on the phone
when he suddenly sees two cigarette
stubs at the toilet and he looks
confused we know that ethan has already
stopped smoking a while ago he then goes
black out again
ethan wakes up and confusingly finds the
security system has been set up around
the house
on the camera footage he discovers that
his body was moving randomly when he
went blackout
we then go back to the previous scene
when malcolm visited ethan to see what
happened to him because ethan did not
respond to his message
surprisingly he sees ethan is smoking as
he is a different person
ethan won't let malcolm come in so he
threatens ethan saying that he will
involve the police if ethan doesn't
cooperate but suddenly ethan attacks
malcolm by injecting something into his
neck
the real ethan wakes up again this time
finding himself in the basement lab
he opens a recording of himself at 1 32
pm
he finds out that that version of
himself is the one who set the security
camera to track his behaviors he
explains that instead of suppressing
emotions they have isolated them making
it split into ten sections including the
default which is the real ethan
he goes black out again and wakes up
finding ally locked in a room
ethan asks her why she is here and she
says that ethan is the one who locked
her in
in the middle of the conversation ethan
suddenly feels dizzy and asks her again
the same question making ally confused
before ali leaves ethan confesses that
he now has 10 personality sections which
shifts from one section to another every
six minutes and will repeat every hour
because of that he asks for ali help
hoping that they can figure out what
really happens
the clock displays 5am it is when the
default ethan comes back
he then continues his previous
explanation that his primary self is
only conscious for the first six minutes
and then he will go blackout leaving his
other newly isolated personalities to
wreak havoc he can't remember for the
other 54. a video of the intellect
section the smartest ones pops up again
stating that the headache while shifting
is going to get worse and worse
thus they have to figure out the
reintegration as soon as possible he
also commands ali to get back at 6.30
because it is the time when the
intellect section takes place
now ali's job is to discover the other
eight sections
long story short ali manages to map all
the sections excluding section 8. they
then observe the section 8 behavior from
the recording video finding that he is
the exact same as the default version
except the section 8 smokes he also
spots that section 8 reads a notebook
but when he tries to examine the book
the six minutes duration has ended and
he goes blackout
when ali tries to message malcolm she
suddenly hears a vibrating phone voice
from one of the rooms shockingly
discovering malcolm is locked in that
room
ali questions ethan but they assumed
that it was section 8 who locked him up
she tries to call the police but is
rejected by ethan saying that they will
go to the prison and the work will be
useless he suggests swiping all malcolm
memories after the 10 south african rant
is ready
moving to another scene in the basement
lab we see that ethan's condition is
getting worse
on recording the intellect section
states that the highest functioning ones
will be experiencing the worst side
effects and they still have six hours
left before the brain is fully dead he
also finds out that all this time ally
has been talking to the intellect
section without telling him the only way
is to find the right equation so that
the brain will reintegrate and reboot
ethan and ali do an examination of the
lab's equipment finding out that the
cooling system is broken they try to fix
it with duct tape hoping that it won't
burn
when they examine the book to see the
equation that was written by the
intellect they find that the page has
been ripped by someone presumed by
section 8. ali examines the calibrated
brain map of section 8 and finally
figures out that section 8 is a
psychotic section who is going to try to
map himself across ethan's consciousness
ethan then goes black out again but this
time he manages to push through adding
six more minutes for the default ethan
because they can't get back the missing
page and the intellect is already too
sick to help they have to rewrite the
equation from the beginning
suddenly ethan recalls his memory and
figures out that there is another
equation which he wrote during the
blackout they finally find the right
equation but there are still 15 seconds
left before the blackout
the default ethan finally discovers that
all this time malcolm has been sedated
and locked in the room by section 8.
ethan becomes panicked and states she
has let the intellect use her he urges
ally to run the memory wipe procedure
immediately and let malcolm out but when
they start the procedure the device is
overheated frying malcolm's brain but
fortunately he is still alive
the scene moves to another cycle this
time when the default ethan watches a
video recording he discovers that the
section 8 already figures out how to
push through making him more dangerous
and the reintegration procedure must be
done immediately
when ali comes back she is approached by
ethan and he asks ally to give the final
equation luckily aldi figures out that
it is actually the section 8 ethan
pushing through ethan insists but ally
manages to hit his head with a wine
bottle
knowing that section 8 ethan will escape
from the room she tries to manipulate
him by changing the clock
section 8 ethan manages to escape and
input the equation to the computer
program
ally knows that she needs to buy some
time until the next cycle so that the
reintegration will occur to the default
ethan so she decides to kiss him and
ethan is shifting just in the right time
the situation finally goes back to
normal ethan is no longer having the
blackouts he decides to pass over the
project to ali and ali is the one who
gets the credit of the university
awarding ceremony at the end of the film
ethan visits a building which is named
after his father but something is
strange because ali then spots ethan who
start smoking indicating that it is not
the default ethan but actually still the
section 8 who managed to push through
again subscribe to watch more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching